kamera läuft blick hinter die kulissen
beim neuesten video dreh mit dem
österreichischen jagd kommando mit dabei
am set verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner bin nicht das erste mal seit aber
heute bei einem ganz wichtigen 3 wir
holen mit diesem video unserer soldaten
vor den vorhang diejenigen die mit
besonderer ausbildung mit ganz
besonderem können mit ganz besonderer
leistungsbereitschaft diejenigen sind
die helfen die schützen und die
verteidigen wir können stolz sein auf
unsere soldaten und das zeigen wir in
diesem video gezeigt wird unter anderem
die befreiung einer geisel
schon bei der ersten videos jahre vor
zwei jahren war hat ist ein großer
erfolg
gerade für uns das jahr kommando weil es
einen sehr großen zuspruch in der
bevölkerung gefunden hat und ich bin
froh dass wir auch jetzt wieder bei der
neuen serie wieder dabei sind und gleich
als erstes wieder starten können die
einsatzszenarien des jagdkommandos sind
vielfältig dazu gehören auch einsätze im
ausland stichwort flint lockt 2020 die
übung flint lockt ist eine übungs jahre
wo afrikanische staaten besser in der
lage versetzt werden sollen für die
eigene sicherheit und damit auch für die
stabilisierung zb der saar raums zu
sorgen mit der ausbildung afrikanischer
armeen zum beispiel im senegal so
langfristig der einfluss von diversen
rebellengruppen zurückgedrängt werden
das österreichische jagdkommandos bildet
seit 2008 sind die ersten kampfschwimmer
der senegalesischen marin aus das ist
ein relativ junges ausbildungsprogramm
der ghanesischen marine
hier gibt es eine kooperation auch mit
den niederländern euro bis 2018
beteiligt sind an der ausbildung dieser
soldaten und jetzt geht es auch darum
dass die zur richtigen kampfschwimmer
ausgebildet werden und da haben wir das
jahr kommen
eine schon gut expertise und haben heuer
damit begonnen und ist noch geplant dass
diese ausbildung zu keinem schwimmer
auch fortgesetzt wird
alle die sich für eine intensive
ausbildung beim österreichischen jagd
kommando interessieren sollten sich das
nächste jahr also 2021 im kalender rot
anstreichen zugang
die ausbildung ist selektiv und relativ
lange wir haben gerade nächstes jahr
wieder ein beginnendes auswahlverfahren
den neuen ausbildungszyklus wofür wir
jetzt schon die werbetrommel rühren und
deswegen ist auch gerade diese videos
jahre ein sehr gutes mittel das wir
gerade die jungen die geht der
österreicher ansprechen dass sie zu uns
kommen weil wir sind ja ja kommen also
daten für die österreicher und
rekrutierungs auch aus den jungen
österreichern und werden im nächstes
jahr wieder einen ausbildungszyklus
laden ab nächster woche gibt es das
neueste video des jagdkommandos bei uns
zu sehen
der erfolg dieser produktion scheint
vorprogramm zu sein
das video wird das ganz besonderes
interesse stoßen dafür kunden wir uns
jetzt schon bei diesen dreharbeiten
überzeugen weil eine besondere
leistungsbereitschaft unserer soldaten
hier auch zu sehen ist und bilder sagen
schlichtweg immer mehr als worte
gab